they extended the battlefield hardline
beta an extra 24 hours on Monday and
that means we had to do the thing that
we do best which is do some testing
so our first burning question was how
much passive protection do you get from
the riot shield whether on foot or in a
vehicle so we wanted to run a quick
control test just to show you that you
can indeed kill people when there aren't
enough other people in the server with
you but we started with a rear test
because honestly I feel like I run
around with this thing a lot and I have
no idea how much rear protection it's
giving me and here we see proof positive
that it's giving full protection nothing
penetrates that there's still
suppression that we can see but no
penetration yeah I was really surprised
unlike in battlefield 4 the riot shield
doesn't like explode after a certain
amount of damage and apparently the
isolate isn't even vulnerable we just
pumped pretty much an unlimited amount
of rounds into this thing in it it held
up now here's the other question though
if I get into a car and Hotwire and I'm
hanging out the side of the car am I
getting any protection from that riot
shoe yeah because the model doesn't show
that it's on your back but the question
is is it really there and it's just not
showing this was a beta after all I'm
not seeing it I'm not seeing a riot
shield so yeah
taking damage conclusion if you're the
enforcer rad shield on your back does
not help you in cars in Hotwire mode so
speaking of driving around in your car
and needing protection there is a perk
called stunt driver and what does that
do stunt driver is basically a nitro
boost it's all class although I tend to
only roll mechanic for the most part
whenever playing Hotwire because they
have the best gear for that mode but we
were trying to figure out does it really
make that big of a difference so there
we go definitely pulling pretty handily
ahead of the car without the boost but I
gotta say let you know if you had people
in your car that wouldn't be fast enough
to not get killed by passengers in the
car
it seems like the stunt driver ability
basically helps for where people have
gotten their time
so down like even just two maybe three
days into the beta people were landing
320 spot-on on the cars that were flying
by same thing with RPGs and if you have
a vehicle that moves at a speed that if
people don't expect them less likely to
date you speaking of mechanics there's
the body armor for the mechanic so the
question is how much protection are you
actually getting from this thing so the
difference was pretty significant with
the pistol it literally took twice as
many shots to the chest down a player
assuming that your arms weren't swinging
in front of the vest and you weren't
taking arm shots now we also tested it
with an SKS and it took about two more
shots to kill somebody with the vest
that can make the difference in a 1v1
gunfight but I will say that there's so
many other places you can get hit in
this game that the chances of all the
shots landing in your chest and not
kicking up to your head or kicking out
to a limb I think are pretty low I'm
gonna go out on a limb here and say
there's probably other gear and a lot of
modes you could be using that's more
useful the next thing that we had to try
was probably my favorite thing to do in
Battlefield Bad Company which is trying
and kill a guy or at least mark and kill
a guy with a tracer Dart
so we found out that the tracer dart
does about three to five a piece which
I'm not even sure why you would bother
it at that you think why even have it
damage people at that point but the
answer is yes it just takes an
impractically long period of time to do
so does that mean that if you've really
got nothing else it is actually worth
taking a shot with the tracer Dart I
think you have a better chance suiciding
and using another life than using the
tracer right now I will say you can use
the tracer dart for literally the most
elaborate way to kill somebody in
battlefield hardline and bad company 2
which is to mark a target and then use
your own battle pickup to kill them a
single person target haha so you know if
a real recon player is ever really
bothering you and you really want to get
them without just you know going the
sniper route which is easy anybody can
do it this would be this is better than
teabagging
all right and the last thing that we had
to test on our last day of the beta was
can you grapple to any crazy places in
battlefield hardline so one of the two
useful places that we found you can get
to is this radio tower on dustbowl you
can get up here and put down a satellite
phone
so your team can spawn on it I caught
the other team off-guard a couple times
during that but also the floor greats
can't be shot through which makes me
think that they might patch this out so
you're invulnerable the most things
except explosives once you get up there
now a few times when I was playing heist
I encountered enemy and some pretty
improbable places what about what about
on bank job on bank job I'm not going to
call this useful but you can run into
the central atrium and actually get up
inside of the dome I guess as the police
it could save you some time I've also
seen the police get through the top of
the dome I I tried but did not succeed
so another place that we found is you
can actually just go straight up through
the middle of the bank right to the roof
so this is kind of a good sneaky route
to plank teams now whether this is
useful or not I don't know what do you
think Ryan I'm gonna say useful I've a
few times got rolled with the grappling
hook coming from the police side and
getting up to the roof and beating the
thieves to the roof top charge can be
very helpful so those were pretty much
the top 5 things that we took the last
24 hours of the battlefield hardline
beta to test battlefield hardline is out
on March 17th maybe we'll have patched
some of these things that we enjoyed or
didn't enjoy I foresee not being able to
make it to the roof of the bank job
until then stay tuned to game spot comm
for more coverage of battlefield
hardline
got the charge on I got eliminated